this presentation is delivered by the
stanford center for professional
development
welcome to the stanford seminar in
people computers and design uh next week
we are on thanksgiving break
and so there will be no talk we'll
resume in two weeks
today we have james landay and uh
james has had a really fantastic career
to date
and i wanted to share with you two
reasons why i think his career has been
particularly impactful one of them is
that so james got his phd from carnegie
mellon
in 1996 and he was one of the first
technical people in the hci community
to really champion design he's been an
early and persistent champion
of the role of design and human computer
interaction and in bringing it into the
fold for the field
and in teaching its methods and he's had
a huge influence there
another thing to know about james is
that the number of students who he's
advised who have gone
on to do all sorts of cool things
some of them are are you know slackers
like me but
many of the students have gone on and
done great things uh
including faculty positions at a wide
variety of universities
and leading industrial research
positions and a bunch of other stuff and
i think that
what's remarkable is that many of his
former students are doing really
different stuff and so it's not like he
built
10 clones of himself but he's figured
out how to
foster a community that really helps
people
find their own way and succeed for
themselves and
watching that community continue to grow
and blossom has been
extremely cool and now he's going to
tell you about
his next biggest venture which is world
lab
yeah i mean really what scott says
academia it's really about the students
and i've been really lucky to work with
them
lots of really really really great uh
smart students but just great people
like scott and jeff and
many others what i want to talk about
today is
what scott said world lab and i'm going
to talk about design and i'm going to
talk about technology
um but one thing you might not know
about me i
was a professor at berkeley and then
i've been at
the university of washington for 10
years including a stint running an
industrial research lab there for intel
um i spent almost three years over the
last four years in china
my family and i went and lived in
beijing took a sabbatical that just kind
of
kept extending you know something nice
about the university they say i'm going
to stay away a little while
and that time in china was really
important for me
culturally important for me with respect
to my career
important for my family because right
now in china it's a really exciting time
you really
feel it in the people that they see it's
an important time in their history
politically economically socially
but china also has a 5 000 year history
of civilization
and it was interesting to me to see how
people
actually take stories and idioms from
that history and use it in their
everyday thinking and and speech and so
i'm going to start out with a story for
you from china
and use this as part of my talk so
what you see here is this bronze
galloping horse
this is a horse that was
made in solid bronze it's 2 000 years
old from the han dynasty
it was only uncovered in 1969 in the
west of china and it's actually an
important cultural symbol it's
the official symbol of tourism china
but what's really interesting is when
they discovered this in 1969 it took
several years
for the experts who were baffled as to
how was this
cast in solid bronze such that it didn't
topple over
because what we see here is the legend
of this
heaven steed was that the horses was so
fast in the west of china that it
literally
flew and so this horse all the hooves
are in the air
except for this one hoof here and it's a
little hard to see that is actually
stampeding on a swallow that is flying
and looking up in horror as this kind of
flying horse is coming by
and so it actually baffled the experts
of how
did this person cast this and solve
bronze as to not fall over and so in
some ways
this horse represents balance to me
it represents balance between the beauty
of the artistry of the horse and between
that design and artistry of that and the
technology to somehow calculate where
the center of mass
would be so it wouldn't fall over and in
fact the center of mass is in
in the in the swallow there at the
bottom
and i actually think finding this
balance
between design and technology hey eric
welcome is is is a really important
theme
in terms of the kind of technologies
that we design and build today
finding this balance between them taking
advantage of our skills
on both sides is what leads to new
technologies that are desirable
so we really need to find this balance
between
for example human centered approaches
that we get from design and human
computer interaction
and more technology centered approaches
from computer science and kind of bring
those together
and even within subfields like human
computer interaction
i feel like we need to find a balance
between careful controlled experiments
of
slightly new things that we invent
versus creating
brand new systems that just totally
change the world in new ways that we
can't
necessarily control that easily and
experiment with and we need to do
both kinds of work and i'm going to try
to talk about some of this as i go
forward
my time in china also leads me to
believe
that we can actually find value by
finding balance between different
cultures
and different ways of thinking for
example this very collective culture
that we see
in eastern cultures versus the more
individualistic culture we see from the
west and that by
seeing things from different
perspectives that actually leads us
to more creativity and new solutions to
problems that we might be attacking
so balance is really key in this way
so in the rest of the talk i want to
discuss three big problem areas that i
think we
as a field should really be working on
and how
looking at them in this balanced
approach between design technology and
also in some instances between cultures
can lead us to interesting new solutions
so
i'm going to start out first talking
about a balance between us
as humans in our environment here you
see lake mead
which is expected to drop below its
intake pipes in the next few years
now you might just say hey don't build
cities in the desert
kind of stupid um you know la
phoenix vegas but the fact is 36 u.s
states
are expected to have major water
shortage problems over the next five
years and global warming
is going to cause this to be more and
more common in many places across the
world we've obviously seen these issues
in africa and other places
for a long time one thing i didn't know
um you know and this is just being kind
of you know as an american we're very
inward looking
going to live in china was that china
has really kind of faced this same kind
of issue
for 50 or 100 years in that a lot of the
population in china lives in northern
china
which is very arid and dry and in fact
when i was in beijing they were
literally
trucking snow and melting it in the
middle of winter to get water for
beijing that there's such a severe water
shortage beijing is pretty much a desert
okay now um in china they're actually
building one of the largest engineering
projects ever which is essentially
to move the water from the three major
rivers in the south
to the north okay this is like a hundred
year project in fact
mal first proposed that i think in 1952
construction started in 2002 and i think
the first
big part of it is coming online just
around now
and it will continue for another 40
years
or so and as part of that project
millions and millions of people are
displaced from their homes
there's huge environmental consequences
of that project and so we might think
about
you know what are things that we might
do in our own lives that might lead us
to not
have such water shortages or use that
resource
better so that maybe we don't need
projects like that
so when i try to think of areas like
this
i want to think as a researcher to think
what would it be a
big audacious goal you know as a not
just for
my research group but as a field what is
something that we could try
um to really achieve so in this area we
might say
could we cut a family's energy and water
use
in a significant way let's say by 50
now you might say hey give me a million
dollars i can build you a house off the
grid and
you know gets its own water and energy
but let's say we said you know for five
or ten thousand dollars could we
take existing families homes and um how
they use
transportation etc the solutions to
these kind of problems i think
are going to involve policy you know for
example we put
higher taxes on gasoline it's going to
change you know how people drive or
if we require higher mileage standards
that's going to have impact so there's
always policy and planning issues that
come into this
um but from what we do here in this room
i think can we think of technologies
that might help with this
as well as design and changing people's
behavior that might have impact in these
problem areas
so i'm going to focus on that design and
technology because those are the types
of things
that we do so for example one of the
projects
that we've done at the university watch
washington is called hydrosense
this was a work really led by my
colleague schwedek patel
working with another colleague james
fogerty and grad student who was leading
a lot of this was john fralick who was
working with me and john is now
professor university of maryland
and really the key insight that they had
was you can think of your pipe
your pipe network in your home as an
information network
and by carefully sensing changes in the
pressure through that
those pipes you could actually sense
very inexpensively
any valve opening or closing in in that
network and tell
what faucets being used in your home and
you could also get a pretty good
estimate for the volume of water used
now this is kind of cool because you can
do it with a really inexpensive sensor
that might cost you know 20 or 30
dollars and
in fact they did a startup and got
bought by belkin who makes all these
iphone and other stuff
and it's going to be available in your
store you know any any month now
supposedly before christmas but maybe
it's gonna fall in the first quarter
and get one of these maybe for a hundred
dollars one sensor
really inexpensively be able to tell us
that's the cool technology
for me as an hci person more of my
interest was well what do we do
with the design how do we use that
information in a way where we might be
able to change
people's actual behavior and just to
give you a better idea here
here's how it works in terms of the
valves opening closing just at the high
level the key thing to understand is
this is someone opening a faucet here at
the top
the middle is a toilet um running and
the bottom is a tub
filling and the key is just to see that
those waveforms look different you know
even the
open faucet and the closed faucet look
different and the toilet opened the tub
open so you can imagine with some
basic signal processing machine learning
you can
learn these different patterns and be
able to detect it and in fact they get
you know in the neighborhood of 95 to 98
accuracy depending on how well you want
to know exactly where in the home versus
the type of faucet and hot versus cold
if you have two of these you get like 99
accuracy so for me the question was
design
and in some ways um this is a lot of
what john
focused on at the end of his
dissertation was how might we use that
information to change behavior
and i put this slide in the other day
because i um
i like to use in my undergraduate class
these kind of hall of fame hall of shame
examples and what i have is always the
smart fridge i'm kind of like
who wants a smart fridge and i was
finding like wait the smart fridge i can
actually use a display in that thing for
something useful
for one so you could imagine maybe in
some high traffic place in your home
maybe it's the fridge maybe it's on some
counter that you have some display that
you look at it on a regular basis
and it shows you kind of your water use
and then the key is how do you design
that in a way that would
cause behavior change so actually john
led a team and literally looked at
dozens and dozens of different design
ideas
that look at different design dimensions
in this area and did this
very extensive online study of something
like 800 people
to look at how they understood these
dimensions and then we did some in lab
studies with people and then in some
in-home studies to understand where they
would
place this technology and so in this
talk i'm just going to show you a couple
of
the examples that i think are very
illustrative of what we were doing
so in this example we have like an
aquatic ecosystem so it's almost like a
gamified water savings
and so here we kind of see your water
savings tracker and if the family met
their goal for the month or the week
then you know this fish meets his mate
and you know if you meet it again they
have some little
guppies or whatever you call baby fish
here
and you know maybe you get a windmill in
there at some point you know it becomes
more of a hipster
aquarium i don't know so and it's also
touch sensitive
kids really like this one that we tested
with some families
another one here is what we call rain
flow and this one was really trying to
get out more of
you want to let people understand what's
the underlying activity
that's tied to their water use because
actually we did surveys with people
um people are really poor at
understanding the top areas that they
use water in their homes
there's three areas that are the most
common and we
found that most people get at least one
of those areas wrong and if not two
and so letting them really understand
for what activities they're using water
might
help them better in this one we can kind
of see you know it's like
showering versus toileting versus
washing dishes or washing clothes
and you might have goals for those
things and if you go over your goal
something bad happens so here again
we've sped it up over time
this design also had the weather and the
date and time and some news headlines
the idea being
there's reasons you would want to glance
at it regularly you know in your home
during the day so that you would start
to
understand this information and again
this one was
on a touch screen so it had this nice
little animation and here we see for
toileting
we go over the goal and it eventually
overflows
okay now the next step in this research
would really be to deploy it in homes
for multiple months and have some kind
of control
and have some great uh ground truth to
understand whether we are
affecting the behavior this didn't get
done yet john got his phd moved off to
be a professor so we need to still do
that
and that's really important you know for
example
i won't say my kids because i said that
in my last talk and they got really mad
they watched it on tv
some kids might think hey let's flush
the toilet a lot to see that display
come out
so maybe this actually this design
actually does the opposite of what you
want so you really
need to actually test these kind of
things in the field
for extended periods and see if you get
the behavior change and then even
further
we need to you as a field understand
what happens when you take them away do
have we change people's behavior or do
you need these things ongoing those are
things the field hasn't even
gotten the right methods to do well
people in behavioral psychology have
done some of this but in hci and cs and
ubicomp
you know most people say that's too much
for a dissertation or too much work and
we're still trying to figure out how do
you make these kinds of studies
easier to pull off we've also worked
in transportation because a large amount
of your
energy usage is in personal
transportation so an earlier project we
did was called ub green
john uh led the authorship of this those
several people including my colleagues
at carnegie mellon led by jennifer
minkoff and students
and the idea here was can we sense your
transportation behavior on your phone
and using the background screen of the
phone give you feedback when your
transportation was green and try to kind
of re encourage you to do those good
behaviors
so as you went through your week you
would see what your most recent
transportation
mode was and these leaves would grow
across this tree
and eventually these flowers would bloom
and at the bottom we also tried to tie
these other values that people felt were
even more important than being green for
example
saving money being calm getting exercise
or being able to do something else while
commuting
um so in this case when you carpooled
you saved money
and when you take the bus here maybe
it's depending which bus you're on i
know some people's buses aren't very
calm
but you know for example the bus over
the bay bridge versus driving i'd say
the bus is calmer
or be able to read and so then if you
met your goal for the week
in this interface design we had these um
apples or fruit appear
and we actually had another interface
design that the folks from cmu were
really pushing
because they had some theories about how
people bonded with animals it would lead
to more behavior change
so there was this other version here
where we had this polar scene and the
more green you were the polar scene
became healthier and healthier and that
the ice grew and there were more polar
bears and they had polar bear babies and
fish and
stuff like that and then if you met your
goal here the northern lights came out
okay and that's what happened um now
there were some surprising results in
the experiments that we ran for this
we kind of thought those ambient
displays you know that
that graphics you just saw there were
just really kind of tell you what you
were doing and give you
information so you would be self-aware
of what your behavior was
so we ran a pilot study all this was
four weeks long and there were 12 people
across two cities
for behavior change this is really a
pilot you're really gonna
be looking at something at least three
to six months long with
that many people or more so this was
kind of shake it out study
so you know there's some informal
results several people wanted to keep
running it that's always good with
research software if somebody wants to
run it on your
crappy old phone like you saw on that
that thing that's a good sign
we saw some behavior change i think some
of our participants were a little too
green already
especially those seattle people though
we have people in pittsburgh
who are like driving three quarters of a
mile to their friend's house and they
said i'm not going to do that anymore so
we
maybe helped the pittsburghers you know
eric you might be able to confirm my
theories there
the thing that i think was the most
interesting research result which was
less related
to this particular problem was people
describe this in the interviews as oh
i'd show the story to my wife or
somebody at work said
hey what's going on with your polar bear
or what does the tree look like now
they almost thought of it as a game in
some ways and to me it was like what
game it's just a
you know display and we had some leaves
you know but people
even with this very simple graphics were
seeing this like a story
and this really led me to believe that
using these kind of really simple
stories
for these behavior change applications
could be a way to drive long-term
engagement because i think one of the
problems
that if you build these type of systems
to deal with is kind of a novelty effect
it kind of seems cool at first but then
you're sick of it
but you can imagine authoring simple
stories like this that people stay
engaged to kind of see what happens and
then maybe you subscribe to a news story
or maybe even have end user contributed
stories they're pretty easy to author
that people could subscribe to just by
getting a theme and not knowing what's
going to happen
so surprising people were fairly engaged
with what i thought was a fairly
simplistic
story so i think we can use that in a
lot of other places
another issue in this behavior change
area
is cultural and this is why i say you
know it's important to understand
different cultures
a lot of the behavior change work we've
done in health
and environment and i'll show you some
health stuff in a minute
is based on a lot of psychology
literature and other literature
bj fogg here has done a lot of work here
at stanford and a lot of this stuff says
you
should stay fairly positive in the
feedback that you give people and if you
give a lot of negative feedback
people are going to stop using your
system i was
in beijing only for a couple of months
and i went to a seminar
at microsoft and a japanese researcher
came in and he had a bunch of interfaces
that looked really similar to what we
had built and i was like
these guys are copying our work what is
this stuff and he didn't know who i was
and he said
now we've seen a lot of this work at
intel in seattle and university of
washington and they have all this
positive
feedback and he said we have negative
feedback because everyone knows in asia
you need negative feedback
okay and i i i was like huh do do you
have some evidence of that is there some
literature
or paper or something he said no but
everyone knows
and they didn't actually test their
stuff so we don't know
but to me that was like oh that's a cool
research question is there a cultural
difference
in this type of feedback so we started
one project there
that i would say is not definitive in
answering this question but leads us
to have some information on it we did an
online study with 180 chinese americans
and in this study they first had to fill
out a standard carbon calculator talking
about their home and their lifestyle and
their transportation
needs and then they got some feedback
from the system on how they were doing
and we manipulated that feedback in a
careful way
some people getting positive and need
feedback and then they had to make
pledges about what changes they would
make in their life and there were
suggestions that they could
grab from this thing to do that and then
they reported back later on which
changes they made in their lives and
these steps happened over several weeks
they weren't all at the same time
so some flaws in this study are it's a
self-report study there's no ground
truth for us to know what's true
but there are some interesting things so
we thought feedback that was positive
would be best based on everything we
knew
it was really interesting for the
chinese participants
negative feedback had the bit led to the
biggest change in pro-environmental
behavior
okay statistically significant
difference for the americans
positive feedback was bigger but i don't
know if it's true it wasn't statistical
difference there
in terms of you know we could look at
the results and say
you know you aren't doing as well as
other people
in in the same kind of have same size
home as you do and things like this so
how we couched how we told them what
their performance was when they did the
carbon calculator
simply that statement how we stated it
being positive or negative
okay and so we were able to control how
we did that to half the people
so again i don't feel like this results
definitive but it's kind of like
i think there's something there and so
again the next step would be for example
if we were doing our water display
uh deployment it would be interesting to
do it in china versus the us
and also manipulate this variable and
see
when we have ground truth does that hold
maybe it doesn't hold
over long periods of time you know maybe
too much negative will get you to not
want to use the system we're not sure of
that
this is again one-time use self-report
so there's some issues but
it's interesting to see at least on the
surface that there was some kind of
difference between these
uh sets of people so culture may
determine how to give feedback in these
kind of behavior change
situations and it certainly shouldn't be
ignored it seems important to
consider the next area i want to kind of
describe about bounce
is really balanced between people and
their own bodies
and balance between exercise and food
and things like this
what you're seeing here is not a map of
what states voted which way
last week but this is actually data from
the center for disease control
and what it's showing is the body mass
index
being greater than 30. 30 means
clinically obese
that's when we start to get a lot of
correlated health issues
diabetes heart disease etc for folks so
this is one they really care about
and what we see is in 1990 most of the
states are a dark green or slightly
lighter green meaning dark green less
than 10 percent of the population of
that state
had bmis a great greater than 30 and
then the other states were 10 to 15
percent of their population
and the ones that are gray mean they
didn't have data um for those states at
this time
now what you're about to see i think
won't be too surprising to people
what's surprising to me is kind of the
speed of this so
as we go through the 90s we see we get
some more yellowing
in the states we start to see some light
oranges
as we get to around 2000 we go colorado
the place to live if you want to be
healthy
you know all those bikers runners
triathletes but even the coloradans
can't keep up with this trend
so as we get through the 2000s we start
to get
those red states getting orange okay
and here's the latest data 2010
okay in 2010 you're looking at
12 states that have about a third of
their population clinically obese
um we have 24 states that have over a
quarter of their population
and then you know the remaining our 14
states are 20 to 25
it's a lot and in fact um if you even
look at just numbers of the population i
think it's
um over 50 percent are now in the
overweight
which is the one category below this or
obese so it's
it's a big problem and i think most of
us knew it i think what was really
interesting when i first saw these
this animation myself was just how
quickly that happened
in 20 years this just went
crazy like this and there's a lot of
different explanations
having to do with you know more of a car
culture or subsidized
corn you know corn sugar uh video games
and people
feeling less comfortable with their kids
playing outside there's all these things
and it's probably some
combination of these things together
but what we're looking at is an epidemic
it's an obesity epidemic
and again this is another problem that
feels to me
worth us spending our time to work on
and see what can we do about it versus
just coming up with the latest
next cool game or something like that so
you know what can we do
from an hci and technology perspective
that might help people with this
now again something was interesting to
me living in china
china's developing world or you know in
the middle of developed and developing
was the us if you ever lived overseas
seems to export a lot of the things
we're less proud of
kind of bad food you'll see mcdonald's
kentucky fried chicken
everywhere bad movies it's like they
don't get the good films
there are good ones they don't just go
and they get the big bad blockbusters
surprising you know even this kind of
obesity and overeating
more than seven percent of chinese
children are obese second only in the us
this comes from the chinese
national task force and childhood
obesity statistics out of china you have
to be
skeptical a lot i'm not sure whether
that's true but definitely you see it
across this burgeoning middle and upper
class 400 million
to 500 million people in china um still
leaving for 500 who are
really poor but that's still a lot of
people who are starting to have money
they're starting to have these western
lifestyles
and especially among boys culturally it
was a tradition that you know you would
eat eat well to show your wealth and
here we see
this was from the people's daily it was
a weight loss camp with a kind of
militaristic theme in uh shanghai that
was in the paper
um so what would an audacious goal here
be
something like can we increase your
physical activity daily by 100
and we can work on the eating thing it's
its own hard problem i have another
project on that but
how about just physical activity okay
could we get those bmi levels back to
1990 might be the other way of
stating this so one project
um that we did at intel and i'll ask
this
take this question in one second was
called you be fit and we were really
trying to attack this issue
what's your question how do you decide
what's a good number
so increasing physical activity
sounds a good idea how do you decide
what's a good goal or a good numbers
question
i don't have a very great way to do that
and i actually thought about these in a
hard way in that
i thought of what would be a hard goal
to reach
you know and does it seem like it'd be
significant you know with the energy one
i could have said 20 and there's a lot
of research backing us up that we know
how to do that right now
so i actually wanted to try to push to
what i wasn't sure i knew how to reach
in that one in this one i think i have
seen
numbers in terms of like what are
recommended daily step counts for people
and what the averages are and it is kind
of
in this territory so i don't know if
that number is exactly what you want and
we probably want to attack the food
issue at the same time so it's again a
piece of the
problem and it's meant to be kind of a
goal that energizes people towards uh
achieving the research yeah gilbert
similar question is do we have any idea
how people's exercise uh food
consumption etc has changed over the
past 20 years
um i mean i mean we i've read articles
about how
you know people are more sedentary and
people are eating more food but i can't
give you like an exact twenty percent
number or anything like that
um so this project called you be fit
um ended up being a phd dissertation for
sonny consolvo who was a researcher at
the intel lab but also pursuing her phd
at the university of washington in our
information school
and the basic idea here was
we felt with mobile computing technology
advancing
that by using sensing and machine
learning
we could actually sense what physical
activity people are engaged in in the
real world
and by understanding what you're doing
and feeding that information back to you
so people could be more aware of what
they were doing because people really
aren't aware of how much they exercise
how much they walk how much they sit at
their desk etc
we could help people meet their goals
and change their behavior because
often people already know they want to
do more they have a hard time sticking
with what their plans are to change
so in this system we had a wearable
device called the intel mobile sensing
platform
which had like 10 different sensors in
it like accelerometers and light sensing
and it had its own processor and storage
and bluetooth
and then we had at the time the best
smartphone you could get
which could barely run the graphics to
you know keep that screen going so we
kind of separated the computing between
these two devices you wear this one on
your belt or something
and then the information would be
transmitted to that phone
so that's a basic architecture of how it
worked and what you see on the
background of that phone
is really the key idea here is what we
call an ambient display
so this garden would start out as just
green grass on sunday
but as you engaged in physical activity
these flowers would grow
and different flowers would appear
depending on what you did so if you took
a walk of 10 minutes or more
a sunflower would appear if you did
aerobic activity like running biking
stair machine elliptical trainer
then one of these orange flowers would
appear and if you did strength training
or stretching which you had to manually
enter because we didn't sense those
the wider blue flowers would appear and
so the idea is
over your week your garden would grow
and if you met your goal for the week
this butterfly would appear
now the basic idea of the ambient
display is not that you look at the
ambient display and say
oh i walked three times and i ran four
times and i did this
the idea was every time you pull out
that phone to check the time
every time you pull out that phone to do
an sms every time you pull out that
phone
to play a game you're seeing that
background screen first before you do
something else
and you're becoming more and more aware
of what your current activity is
and in fact if late in the week it
looked like this
you would feel fairly good about
yourself going to meet my goals i'm
doing well
but if late in the week you know friday
let's say it looked like
this you might feel boy i better take my
gym bag today
or ride my bike to work instead of
taking the bus
and do something to kind of get towards
your goals that was the basic idea
and i think this is an idea that many of
the commercial products haven't
really figured out yet and is one of
their problems you know like here's the
fitbit
everyone likes it it's got cool design
and all this stuff but unless i think to
take it out
and like go hey how many should i step
today
6 000 steps doing okay i won't know
i have to think about it whereas the
idea here is we're taking advantage of
how much you use your phone for all
these other things to
grab your attention but in a subtle way
so
that's what that looked like from a ui
point of design from the underlying
technology we had this intel mobile
sensing platform
it essentially is collecting all these
different sensor readings
at different frequencies and then
calculating features
means medians all kinds of other simple
mathematical
equations on them and then kind of
coming up with an end best list of what
activity you thought you were doing
at each instance okay so like you know
three times a second
it's inferring like walking walking
walking land days walking walking
walking running running running standing
walking walking walking
and then this information was sent over
bluetooth to the phone
which then on an application-wide basis
could figure out
how to smooth that into the what it
needed for that application so for
example for
for ub fit you know it might try to look
over longer periods what you're thinking
it's doing on the other hand if i want
to make an application that
when i'm walking and looking at my phone
it makes things bigger so i can not run
into light posts and things
it might do that much quicker that
smoothing depending on your application
again as i said we originally did this
this paper that tanzim choudhary led a
lot of the machine learning work on this
but
this paper is like a physics paper or
old physics paper with like 20 people
a lot a lot of engineering work
to go from machine learning algorithms
that can be published in
ai conferences and everyone says works
to making it really work on a real
device and
you know do real apps with it that
amount of engineering actually led to a
whole other phd dissertation
uh k or patel just finished on tools for
machine learning was
how because of how hard that was now
um we didn't think people are going to
want to wear these things
we're playing the usual computer science
trick of how do we throw some money at
something to predict the future
by you know throwing things today that
eventually will be miniaturized and
cheap and so only
three or four years after we first
started this we
took one of the first iphones and first
android phones
and one of the windows mobile phones at
the time and rewrote the software and
showed you could do the activity
inference on
stock smartphone and the biggest
remaining thing at that point
was can you do it without killing your
battery and a bunch of researchers at
dartmouth and ucla and other places have
now shown how to
be smart about cycling the sensors to
actually do this so this technology
could be in a good app today without
killing your phone be able to understand
what physical activity you're doing more
than just saying you're walking or
running we really could tell
a bunch of these activities now
there are some surprising results in the
studies here
sunny actually ran both a pilot study
similar to the one you saw there for ub
green earlier that was three weeks
12 or 14 people really to work out the
kinks in the ui and also the activity
inference and
you know we found a bunch of bugs where
you know somebody was sitting in a chair
at home and it said they were biking you
know
mislabeled training data things like
this but then
for the phd dissertation she ran this
much more long-term and careful study
and you know going into this as the
computer scientist in this group and
kind of leading this team
i thought activity inference is the real
key thing this is the thing we've been
working on
for two years make this activity
inference really work this is the key
um but we tested it and we did a three
month field trial
with 28 different people and we had
three different conditions
so in the first condition there was what
i would call the full system they had
everything
activity inference the ambient display
with the garden
and there was also an application you
could run to enter
data for example strength training um or
stretching or correct the inference if
it was wrong like or it just didn't
notice that i went running i could put
it in there
so really three components then we had a
group of people
who had no activity inference they had
to manually enter everything using that
application
but they still had that ambient display
and then we had
a third condition where we had activity
inference but there was no ambient
display the only way you could see your
performance was run the app
and there you would see it but it
wouldn't be there every time you pulled
your phone out you would have
to like me on my fitbit thinking hey how
much did i run i'd have to look at it
okay what was interesting is the study
was run
during a period of time that we thought
was a horrible time to run
an exercise fitness study which was
right now
we had to run the study kind of right
before thanksgiving
in the us and it ran through the winter
holidays and past
new year's and we had to run it at that
time due to
political financial reasons in the lab i
was no longer the lab director and the
next guy said you guys need to finish
this project or we're taking the money
away you know it's like
okay we're going to run the study it
ended up being a great time for us to
run the study we didn't understand it
when we ran it
because there was a lot of prior
literature that
talked about exercise at this time of
year and
shows that people drop off their
exercise
at least living in the northern
hemisphere at this time of year due to
it gets darker especially if you live in
seattle it gets wetter
you know you might even have snow in the
east there's these
holidays where often people are
traveling and they're eating differently
and they get knocked off their routines
and so people drop off what was
interesting is in this study
the only condition where people were
able to maintain their exercise
through that three months was the folks
who had the ambient display
okay whether you had activity inference
or not didn't matter to that and the
people who did not have ambient displays
dropped off as the prior research would
say so
no matter how much i wanted to feel god
key feature was activity inference and i
actually still think it's important in
fact all the participants
said they wanted it and i think over
again long-term use
people drop off in doing um journaling
so i think you still want it
the ambient display is more important in
this case
for the behavior change and is the key
feature and again it's
one that you saw us using ub green later
which we actually did after this project
and also in some of the water displays
a way to communicate to people what
their real behavior is and again
you know the only one of these fitness
things that i think is sort of gets us
is the nike fuel band sort of
has some ambient display but there's
other ones um the one from
jawbone for example again you don't know
it until you like sync it with your
phone
there's a new fitbit where you can start
to look at your phone but there still
haven't figured it out that this is
actually would be the important feature
for making behavior change
we actually try to combine some of these
ideas together at microsoft
in this new one that we call huzuki
and what we were looking at here was in
china
i was curious what would a kind of a
green application in china be
and so being you know an hci researcher
the first thing we did is we did field
work i had some psychology
students from peking university as
interns we went out and did field work
and when we talked to chinese folks
about
green activity and an application to
help them be more green the response was
quite negative
in fact people said i wouldn't want
people to know that i'm green
they would think i couldn't afford water
or i couldn't afford the energy so there
were actually social reasons why you
even would not necessarily want people
to know about this
that we see almost opposite effects here
in the us where like
people want the prius because it's like
a badge that i'm green they don't want
the one that looks just like a regular
old car and just happens to be green
okay and so in china the effect was
opposite though again among a younger
population i think that was starting to
change
but one thing that did come up and one
good thing about doing field work is
listening to people and coming up with
new ideas some of the person said
hey if the green activity had to do also
with my health
then i'd be more interested so people
were interested in health and that gave
us the idea of building an application
that kind of combined some of these
ideas that looked more at your holistic
wellness so it looked at
your environmental wellness your
physical wellness and your mental
wellness and this was huzuki
and you would sort of check into those
activities and
then using the ideas that we talked
about in terms of stories and games
there was this character
zookey who you know you might look at
and go what is zuki yeah it was huzuki
you don't know who zuki is
buzuki has to go over these barriers
like cross this water here
or go over a mountain or climb through a
wall or whatever
and he gives you hints along the way and
as he achieves these things based on
your activity
he starts to reveal more and more of who
he is and so the mystery is revealed
after several weeks or months playing
the game and then maybe you subscribe to
another one so this was kind of an idea
of combining some of these concepts this
one um was in the middle of being built
and actually has not been deployed
um the student who is working on it um
has shifted some other work
so the yeah question what's your name by
the way
uh a couple questions actually so first
uh about the thanksgiving study
uh do you have any idea why people
continue to
exercise was it simply they were trying
to get a little bit of green in the
middle of winter on on the uv fit style
uh yeah the one that we ran over
thanksgiving and winter break yeah
so was it simply that people wanted a
little bit of green
no i mean this was purely about fitness
this stuff
yeah and these are people who chose to
participate in the study who wanted to
be more fit
so they in the in the model of behavior
change they were already
making a plan to change their fitness so
everyone was motivated
to do it so they wanted this is why they
were participating i mean they were
compensated to run the study also
but people wanted to get more fit these
were people who were trying to
improve their fitness
and the goals were based on a baseline
and then trying to improve on that
and those people were able to maintain
their goals through the study
and the other people were dropped off
and were not able to maintain the goals
okay any other questions about the
health uh
before i move to this next area okay so
we had also done
work with elder care in that area too
but i don't have time to talk about it
yeah you mentioned earlier
what degree do you find that you can
take theoretical accounts of persuasion
and motivation and goals and so on and
apply those theoretical insights
into what i said is it more a common
sense matter of trying things out
um goal setting theory um
which is described really well in uh
survey papers by lock and latham
is really one of the key ideas in both
ub greening
ubfit that by having people set goals
and having those goals
appear achievement of the goals appear
in the interface
is one of the really key ideas in there
there's other persuasion techniques that
you could use but that was the one that
we've used a lot and it's worked
but then there's other things that we
learn by doing the work
so for example in that three-week ub fit
study
you could set a goal and if you met your
goal
this butterfly appeared and then when
sunday came around
your your your garden cleared out your
butterfly went away and you start over
well you know you test the stuff for
real and you see what happens well one
thing happened and i know in my own
behavior with the system
come saturday i'm going on a run around
the lake
i'm walking the dog that night maybe
that morning i'm doing whatever it takes
to meet my goal
you know and so a lot of people didn't
get their little butterfly tote
friday night or saturday and then sunday
it's gone
you know like you win the thing and then
boom it's gone so
one change was in the later version this
little
kind of like butterfly would appear off
to the side for the
previous three weeks if you met your
goal so there's some memory of the goal
to kind of remind you you had done well
rather than just hey i got it and then
it's gone
another issue we ran into was let's say
you get a really busy week you have a
grant deadline or a paper and you just
don't get to the gym
and you're just like there's no way i'm
going to meet my goal then you kind of
give up
and he was like forget it there's no
chance so we added this idea that you
could set a secondary goal
that's quite lower and you can't do it
every week but then you still have
something to shoot for and you'd get
like a little butterfly if you
you reached it or it's more like a moth
it was white
um so again those i don't know if those
are in that literature but they're just
ideas that came out of
doing the study that ended up really
succeeding and people really
liked in the in the final system and in
hindsight maybe they would have been
obvious oh yes you should have designed
that but sometimes you just
you got to build it and test it and see
what happens and i thought those were
two cool ideas that came out of
doing the study so the last area
that i'll talk about balance is in
education this one's interesting for me
in that
china and the us i think are fairly
different in this way but it's in a
kind of symmetrical way so in china you
know it's
they've shown that the factory of the
world at least for now before vietnam
and
philippines and other places start
creating all this stuff and
even in education you could say china
has shown that can turn out
top students who come off to stanford
and
come to the us and go to chingua and
peking university
students who you know have worked really
well and scored really high on
on these standardized tests and what was
interesting to me is when i was living
in china
um i think at the end of 2010
there was these international exams that
were given
all over the world among uh middle
school or junior high students
and it's called the pisa and the chinese
students came in number one in the world
at this time and in fact they even beat
the the west in english yeah you know
it's like
you know how could we lose that okay um
and it caused a lot of navel gazing and
consternation in the u.s
at the time i think it was december the
uh president
who jintao was visiting washington um
the tiger mom book came out you know
there was a lot of like oh my god we're
losing here
what was interesting is i was reading
chinese blogs and other things at least
ones that are written in english that i
could read
or listening to interviews with folks
and there were a lot of people in china
actually questioning those results not
saying that they didn't
deserve them but saying is that what we
really want is that really what we want
to achieve
um and people are questioning whether
that chinese educational
system is leading a conformity in
efficiency
and turning out a lot of students who
can take the test and do well but not
teaching creativity and innovation and
educating a populist that's going to be
able to
solve the problems of the future so it
was interesting to me that there was
this undercurrent of questioning
those results going on in the u.s it's
the opposite problem in some ways nobody
says
oh these american kids are not creative
but if you know you look at this
report from the broad foundation 68 of
us eighth graders can't read at grade
level and will never catch up
it's the fundamentals where in america
we
kind of are concerned and we want you
know no child left behind and have all
this testing to make sure we can do the
basics and
hey let's teach singapore math and i'm
actually
advocate of such a thing but you know
again you see both societies um
out of balance in some ways on this
question and in fact the tiger mom book
which i've taken out of these slides is
marketed in china
almost in the opposite way it's marketed
in the u.s says hey we should
be more fundamental like in asia in the
china it's almost marketed as
we need to be more like those us moms
you know
because in china they actually had this
guy the wolf dad who beat his kids
um if they didn't get a's and you know
they all went to peking university and
graduated and that was like success
so she was seen as liked the tiger mom
okay so education i think is a much
harder one to think about
you know you know if if you have
problems with those numbers i gave you
before this one's even harder to go what
what's the goal here
what should you try to achieve so you
know one goal might be could we help
kids
whether they're from rural china our
inner city chicago perform
you know within the top 10 or 20 percent
of those kids in shanghai
who by the way were from some really
very select schools
versus the u.s ones were a little
broader so there's even a little cookery
in those numbers so
could we do that now on the other hand
that might just
produce good test takers maybe that's
again not what we wanted in fact
this quote i like is attributed to da
vinci there's some
controversy on the internet whether he
actually said it but i like it anyway so
i've been impressed with the urgency of
doing knowing is not enough we must
apply
being willing is not enough we must do
to me this is about balance actually
you got to know the fundamentals you got
to learn the basics but then you got to
use it
you got to solve problems you got to
build things you got to create things
and those together are how you really
learn
that that's what it says to me some
other people have taken this quote to
mean
you don't need school just get out there
and do stuff i think you actually need
need both okay so peter theo maybe we'll
read this in a different way
um so maybe a more crunchy goal here
even less you know uh numeric would be
you know how do we help kids increase
their creative
activities in school and daily life i
don't know how to even write this one
but
it's kind of um the direction so kind of
a far out project here that we barely
started it's more like we've written
some early proposals about it um is kind
of this idea of a smart primer
has anyone here read neil stephenson's
diamond age
oh wow this is a good audience i usually
get such a low number it's really hard
so anyways this book came out in about
1995-ish
and the idea of the diamond age which
the subtitle of the book is a young
lady's smart primer
was this idea of this kind of think of
it looks like an ipad at least that's
how i see it there are no pictures in
the book
a tablet that's like a novel except the
girl has it she's actually a character
in the story and other girls who have it
they're characters in her story too
and she has to solve real problems in
the real world for the story to progress
and learn things
but it's a novel she has for like 10
years you don't just read it for a month
and you're done it's like
evolves with you and at the time i
remember reading this
in graduate school carnegie mellon with
some of the top ai
grad students in the country and we were
all just we need a perfect ai for this
ever to come to pass so this would never
happen
then the ipad came out and i started
thinking about it i was like wow the
hardware's there
what's the software and i said you know
there's cognitive models of carnegie
mellon for calculus and algebra tutors
and it works well
and there's all this content from khan
academy and you know i got scott and
others teaching coursera there's stuff
out there
to me the hard part and we got wikipedia
and we could crowdsource different
characters or different people to me the
hard part is kind of the design hci part
how do i create a story that weaves that
stuff in a way that you would actually
want to read it and keep interacting
with it for years rather than months how
do you engage
i actually think you know there's some
people do interactive drama and stuff
like that
that we actually could start to build
such a thing
it might be still a 10-year project and
require a lot of things but i think
this could be a different way to look at
education so there's a lot going on with
massive online courses and things like
this that
kind of take traditional model of
education and get it out there
in uh online i think those things mainly
apply to people who are very motivated
already by the current system and just
don't have the time or they live in the
wrong place they don't have money
i actually think thinking about things
like this might actually allow us to get
to people who the current system just
doesn't address
you know they're not interested they're
not motivated so looking at something
that's very different way
to look at education maybe is something
we do here again this is just
like an idea that hey you want to work
on it talk to me
i have one person one student who's
starting to look into the beginning of
this so some
early steps though that we've done here
to look into this one
are in terms of language learning
in microsoft uh working with my
colleague there darren edge we had this
idea
learning chinese is really hard any
expat living in china
all they talk about is how hard learning
chinese is
it takes about 2 500 hours to learn
chinese if you're an english speaker
it takes only 500 hours to learn a
romance language so it's like
five times as hard i like to say i've
had 300 hours of one-on-one chinese
tutoring
that's kind of equivalent to i've taken
french one maybe french two
okay i can get around but i can't have a
conversation
so we're trying to think how can we do
education in your everyday life
in between moments so for example let's
say you had this bluetooth headset in
your ear
and you're sitting at a restaurant i'm
waiting for my friend eric to come he's
busy
he's going to be late and so it knows
i'm in a restaurant and maybe
it starts to prompt me to practice my
chinese and it says
how do you say can i see a menu and
i think in my head the answer and
unfortunately in chinese for some of us
westerners check and menu
are sort of similar chinese people are
just like what they are trust me
okay and so i think the wrong answer and
then this
text the speech comes back with the
right answer and i'm like damn i mixed
those two up again
and then using my muscle computer
armband that uh student of mine scott
ceponus developed as part of his phd
with destiny 10 at microsoft
i could self-grade myself you know put
fingers together i got that wrong
people don't know what i'm doing but i'm
learning okay
and so this was the basic idea of this
system and just to give you a little bit
more do i have to do anything to turn up
the sound on
here actually i need audio output
i didn't plug this in sorry anyone know
where that
cord is looks like this
if we can get some sound
good all right let's see how so here's
an idea of what
this might look like
how to say subway
subway um
thank you
how do you say have you got a subway map
um
your mail detail teacher
oh i mix up map with the dress
can you understand
um when you get on the subway behind the
doors
when you get on the subway be careful
after three dogs
yes i'm a genius
hmm i need to get off soon i think
i already know how to say it let me show
you something else
hopefully i'll get a human translation
before i need to get off
yeah i'm a chinese
so again um that was just an
envisionment of what we wanted and we
didn't have the muscle armband in fact
he was just thinking you could just tap
and with the accelerator
accelerometer no yes versus no one tap
versus two
there's this idea that you might have
this online community or crowdsource
getting better translations because if
you've tried to do chinese or other
languages google translate works pretty
well
but when you get down to really needing
something right it often doesn't work
so you probably want people involved and
that video boy we made it and it made me
realize boy i've been saying this the
wrong way for a year
um how to get people to move on the
subway um
so the first real thing we built for
this is something called micromandarin
paper on this appeared at kai last a
year ago
essentially context-based flashcards on
your iphone we thought hey this is a
much better way to learn stuff
using the context of what your location
is bring up words that are relevant and
learn them in that context and you'll
remember them better so we did that we
built it
and we ran a study and you know
we thought contacts flash cards would
work better than what we call frequency
based
in the frequency based case what we did
is we took the
most common characters in chinese
language and
from a lexicon and then trained you on
those first
so we ran a study comparing these it was
within subjects
four weeks two conditions 23 people and
what did we find out
it was actually a mixed result more
experienced people who i'd call more
intermediate or expert people
much preferred the context way and
novices
hated it they really preferred the
frequency and
i guess in hindsight it makes sense you
got to learn some basics before you
could do much
but then when you're more advanced you
kind of want stuff that fits with the
real world a little better or with what
your actual situation is at the moment
so i think in a real system you probably
want to offer
these two different ways to get at it
rather than just think one way is the
right way
both of them are good but it depends on
the situation
so these are the three different areas
that i wanted to talk about in terms of
balance where we're looking at both
a new technology as well as design and
in fact even in this case the design of
how you would use things
in the real world and there's underlying
technology darren's posts other papers
about
even understanding the forgetting model
for people on these kind of flash cards
and what's the right
pattern to reshow them won the best
paperwork at mobile
hci um this year so there's
both technology and design to try to
solve these problems but
i think some of the lessons that i've
brought to me from my time in china and
working on these kind of projects both
in the us and china
leads to a new style of design that i'm
at the moment calling global design
and i think for us to solve these
problems in health and education and the
environment
we need to take this approach that's
more human centered
it's more social it's more fun but we
also need to think about the technology
you know what happens when we have a
hundred thousand times as much
computation
and storage on our body what what can we
use that for what new things
is that going to enable so try to think
beyond just kind of hey what's the next
chi paper i can write or
nsf proposal i can do what's a bigger
thing you might try and i think to solve
these kind of hard
problems requires a few things one is
what i call this
design technology symbiosis and you know
maybe in silicon valley this is commonly
thought of but you actually need to do
it where we have designers and
technologists
working very closely together maybe this
is the kind of thing that happens here
at the d
school really closely together taking
advantage of those two different ways of
thinking
to solve these problems i think is
really important these areas and you've
seen it in some of these problems i
showed you where there was really a
interesting technology uh consideration
like schwedick noticing pressure could
just tell you what's going on in your
pipe network
but then from a design perspective
saying hey just showing people graphs
like google did for energy isn't going
to cut it in terms of
making people understand whether where
their usage is and so
trying to make sure you're focusing on
both sides to solve these problems
the other one is leveraging diverse
culture okay so getting beyond making
sure we have
these multiple skill types among our
people or at least among our teams
having different cultures gets people to
think out of the box and
solve problems different ways there's
some studies showing that people who
travel the world more are more creative
now we don't know if it's causation or
correlation you know one theory is
that by seeing even basic things done a
different way in different places
like hey toilets are different in this
place it causes you to think
more of hey what if i do this other
thing different it causes you to think
more what if
changing the assumptions that you've
grown up with
so i think this is important and then i
think this important one for many of
these areas especially education and the
environment
is how do we get longer term engagement
a lot of what we do in hci has been
oriented for 40 years about designing
for fairly short-term
tasks and many of the lingo and other
techniques we teach in our courses
are really task-based but how do we
start thinking about designing for
activities that go over
months or years like learning language
you don't learn chinese
in a few hours okay changing your
environmental behavior it's going to
take a while
getting fit you know i might want to
lose 20 pounds it's not going to happen
next week
it's something's going to take time and
effort how do we design around those
things i think it's really important
so in terms of these problems that i
think are fairly global
i've noticed at the time of who gentile
visiting the u.s
a lot of people a lot of the press was
about how we're in competition with
china and this is
the next great race between east and
west etc
i actually feel for these problems it's
a world problem we live in one world
especially the environmental one between
us and china we don't solve that
together it's
not going to be solved by anyone because
that's where all of this energy use is
happening
and so it's really important i think
that we go beyond small collaborations
and try to do something more significant
in tackling these proposals so one thing
i've been trying to create
is a new institute that's oriented
towards this it's called the world lab
the idea is to be the place for taking
these risks breaking the mold
really going after these hard problems
you're not going to solve them in one
year
it's not to say you're not going to do
shorter term research that leads to new
papers and proposals but
having these big goals that are long
term
kind of re-energizes and changes how you
think about your research
and this could be the kind of pro place
to do that
try to have this balance between
academia and industry between east and
west between design and technology so
having
people come from these different areas
two sites to start why say we just do
this in one place
so initially i've been talking with
folks at ching hwa
in both computer science and design that
have relationships and we
started this with myself and others at
uw
the real key is this cross flow that you
have people go back and forth
for these cultural things you can't
simply say hey yeah we'll skype you know
and you know really collaborate you
really need for example let's say a
master's program where you spend a year
in china you're in the us or a phd where
you do four-year
in your country in two years another and
faculty who say hey yeah every five
years i'll go over there for a year and
it's not just going on sabbatical to
hang out and go to nice restaurants it's
like i'm going there to do work
okay and then then you're going to start
imagining
interesting technology so for example
let's say this was my lab here in
washington in the foreground
and behind that glass wall was a lab in
beijing in chingua
okay and we could have awareness of
what's going on on the other side
not a lot of overlap for me hours wise
so the grad students work very crazy
hours so may we get more overlap
but you have awareness of what's on the
tables what's going on and you can walk
up to that window
and have a conversation there's folks in
the graphics and vision community
who are building such systems we imagine
studying much more from the hci
perspective
across the world like this who would you
want to have in these places
i think the real key is this maker
culture
designers and folks who are doing
computing but i take both of those areas
quite broadly so for design also i think
of architecture and planning and art
as these maker cultures in computing we
have ee and me people and physicists
people who create
stuff and then we also need folks who
understand people
so psychology sociology understand
ethnography and also
business understand policy behavior you
need all of these people though i think
the key
core is really these makers on the
design technology end
is who should be the primary people you
want to have in this place
now you might say why do you want to do
this it's pretty hard to
create something across the pacific it's
hard to deal with china
qinghua they're very engaged with the
government it's very complicated
besides just that i feel these problems
need to be solved kind of
between the us and china it's important
there's actually some practical reasons
so one is
as i mentioned in the beginning the
energy you sense
among the people in china and the energy
among the young technologists and
designers is something you really want
to tap into
and there's also energy among the
government they've had increasing in
scientific funding
of 15 to 20 percent for 10 years
straight okay so there's funding going
into this now you take numbers with a
grain of salt it doesn't all go into
research
there's this maker culture as they
become this factory of the world you're
getting people who build things
they need it for design reasons good
design pays the ipad iphone they're some
of the most successful consumer products
ever it says designed by apple in
california assembled in china on the
back
though out of 500 iphone only about
seven dollars stays in china
about 25 to 50 goes to japan 25 to 50
goes to korea and apple keeps over 200
because it's their design so in china
they want to educate people who are
going to be able to come up with some of
these products in the future
from a us perspective the market you
know you've seen these numbers i'm sure
but it's huge
1.3 billion people over a billion mobile
phones 600 million people on the
internet and growing all the time
it's huge and you can't just drop in an
executive there for a few months
and understand the culture and be able
to take advantage of it you have to
actually live there and learn it and
in fact now i feel like i'm getting a
phd in china in some ways in that it
shows you how much i don't know it just
kind of
leaves you with questions it's
complicated how do we do this
really in steps we start with exchanges
then maybe a joint master's program
then some faculty positions a phd
program and then the final frontier in
all of academic pursuit
space okay the hardest to ever get so
this is where we are now
exchanges um we did it this summer
something called the world lab summer
institute
i had 11 beijing students come to
university of washington then together
with nine seattle students we had 20
students
five teams of four almost half chinese
half us on each side
half designers half technologists they
worked for seven
weeks boot camp they had morning
lectures afternoon work on their
projects and then we took them to tours
of some of the top research labs in the
area
google microsoft adobe and then fun
boeing factory tour that if you've never
been should go see how they
make this stuff um just to give you a
little flavor
for what they did before i conclude here
so
so that just give you a flavor the
projects they did
used a lot of techniques you see in the
undergraduate hci courses here from
paper prototyping
to really really high-end finished
concept videos
those are on the web if you go to the
world lab site i don't have time to show
you them but
they did projects in environment trying
to encourage recycling
a couple in education one for kids to
encourage to do
things with their parents out of school
and another one for sharing different
perspectives on
world topics and then uh
also one for kids learning how to
express emotions through drawings and
then finally
this one in uh kind of similar to you be
fit trying to encourage people to
exercise in little bits more in their
daily life with kind of this
projected tattoo on your arm watch that
video it's quite cool let me skip
through these
um a lot of people helped work on this
couldn't have done it without this
industry
support as well as um support of my
endowed professorship that
um from short dooley and um finally i
want to leave you
with this chinese saying for the chinese
folks uh
apologize my bad chinese
and i was surprised when i first read
this i actually could translate this so
i maybe learned a little more chinese
than i thought
this means 10 years to grow a tree 100
years to educate people which kind of
says
that education is a long-term important
investment to the future and prosperity
of our society
and to me this is what the world lab
idea is all about
and i appreciate your comments
afterwards and questions and help in
making this a reality and so i thank you
for your time
you